computer because you all made a mistake
not really no so you want to get mad and
hit the computer
because you made a mistake because your
company made a mistake
you want to take it out on me so why
don't you get mad and hit the computer
why did you get mad and hit the computer
i'm sure you on camera right
yeah i'm gonna shoot you on camera
so this is the type of people that here
working here
wow
you gotta be kidding me
you saw this on on social media yeah i
did
i did i did man this is a tough one i
saw everyone kind of
uh you know posting this tariq nasheed
had a one of the most eloquent forms of
race baiting i've seen all year and he
titled it a
white hotel employee has a nervous
breakdown when a black
customer tells him he made a mistake
making it inherently a racial thing
and in the comments everybody was
laughing and clowning him and basically
meaning him
and you know we're in the middle of a
pandemic people have lost their jobs
people are suffering street forms of
loneliness the rates of mental health
disorders are skyrocketing
and when someone's having a nervous
breakdown they're clearly in a crisis
by all indications when you look at this
person that's what it is it's very
obvious this is someone who's having a
manic depression of sorts like
you could see it everyone was so much
concerned with themselves
and how it would make them look like you
know what sometimes i understand you
know if a hotel
is not treating you well you want to
film your customer service interaction
but when you see someone having a mental
health breakdown
why would you go through the process of
not only continuing filming but
antagonizing them
and then beyond that going to post it on
the
internet that's the step
that i'll never understand there was a
couple of years back there was another
video of a of a hotel clerk
and she had big eyes and she was like
okay what's your reservation
it really looked like she was tweaking
and [ __ ] you're gonna post that
like you have to understand when you're
posting stuff like that what the
ramification is
but that's what people do they present
themselves like that
to have the people are so occupied and
being viral
and having the next big story that they
present themselves like that and
sometimes they're gonna
antagonize people together just to have
that reaction and that's what i think is
very wet
yeah and the person in question has come
on said yes i do have bipolar disorder
which
i didn't even need a confirmation but
it's good to have this person
said that they're schizophrenic and this
is where the job where you know
people are working with him to be able
to help him get work and if you already
know how hard it is to work
as a person with mental health issues
for you to see someone struggling and
then want to post it online and further
stigmatize them like
man i don't play with this [ __ ] i know
people in my personal life who clearly
have mental health issues
and who are not addressing them there's
such a stigma surrounding it
and so when people trust look at it see
someone having a mental breakdown
and choose to actively go and make that
whole thing worse by posting them online
and and feeding into their paranoia
it just blows my mind that people don't
see anything wrong with that well i work
for hotels i work for customer service i
did a main job in customer service
yeah uh first thing i'm gonna say before
i go in a lot of these establishments do
not care about the employees
or they let
their employee face
the problems that there is in the
industry
in in the corporation in that work
there's a lot of problems sometimes
and they do nothing about it because ah
well having a better working
uh software would cost too much having
this would cost too much it's not
cost this cost that i remember when i
was working at a hotel
at a hotel there's a lot of things that
were lacking and they were not fixing
the problem
and people ended up leaving the job and
they were always
trying to put the pressure on the people
working at the hotel
then fixing the problems unfortunately
there's a lot of corporations that are
like that
and there's the people that are what we
call front line workers people that are
on the front line they're going to be in
front of the customers
that gets all the [ __ ] and they try to
cope they're basically the
thing between the customers and the
company so
the company doesn't do their job though
the people working up to
up there are not doing their job so it's
the people from the front work
that are they have to do everything that
he can
to absorb what the client is telling
them and all the hardship that a client
is telling them that's the first thing
that i see
in that video that i saw there was
probably problem and we kept that person
was
that person is under a lot of stress
because he's at the front desk there's a
lot of standard
there's a lot of there's a lot of
pressure being at that position
now you know nobody asked them to not
choose that job i understand that
but the first issue that i see there is
there's things that are not working and
stuff like that and there's a lot of
pressure
which are not taken care of oftentimes
the second problem that i have with is
why do you for before you start hitting
himself you saw that it was a problem
i'm talking about the person that is
filming you saw that it was a pro
automatically you film it we're at the
in this era that we're
we're filming people right there and
then instead of being like trying to
work with what's going on and stuff like
that
so we went there oh okay there's an
error with my reservation
i you're gonna learn today and we film
and we present ourselves like that
the person sees the camera but they
can't do nothing about it
right uh the third thing a lot of people
are gonna be like their first thing when
they're gonna see this is to start
laughing and stuff like that
mental issue is not something necessary
to laugh about
i feel bad for that dude maybe it's
because i've seen people having a mental
breakdown because
maybe it's because i've seen this thing
happen you're filming someone that has a
mental breakdown like this guy is
obviously
not well but you keep on filming him
like oh wow
and you keep on pressing putting more
pressure maybe it's because you didn't
know but you keep on putting more
pressure
he got triggered that's someone that got
triggered by something
obviously i'm not saying that he should
be doing this job i'm not saying that he
necessarily has the help that he had
that he was supposed to receive
but you filming and continuing to put
pressure
you're not helping you're absolutely not
helping and now you're gonna post it on
social media for what for that person to
get fired for that person to lose his
job
for that person to lose whatever he's
able to have to pay for
i think there's a lot of things that are
wrong with that but
maybe i have a different thing and you
know the first thing that i said in that
video when i said like you know what
there's a lot of people that put
pressure and stuff like that
that was just something that i try to
relate to it doesn't even mean
that the hotel that he works at are like
that
but it's a possibility well he feels
like they are he said that there he said
that these corporations don't care about
us and it's time for him to quit
so he quit and he's going to go take
care and it's true what you said about
like the people on the front bearing the
brunt
of the [ __ ] that the corporate folks
do and the strain that it puts on them
mentally
what you said is true they don't care
they don't do not
give a crap and whenever those issues
are reported
people do not the people in the they
don't do [ __ ] about it
i remember like i was working in a
five-star hotel dude
we had a problem with we didn't have
enough cups
for coffee and stuff like that for the
service we didn't have
the resources were lacking bruh so what
i had to do i would try to tell them i
tried to tell them and me
and you know me being petty i'm gonna
tell you once i'm gonna tell you twice
but at the third time
i'm gonna put even if i'm working in a
corporation right there i'm going to
choose of course the moment where i'm
going to do that
we had a union and stuff like that so i
was under union
but i'm to make things better i'm good
because i like my job i love my job but
the incompetence of the people above
me was astonishing and confident they
were not
the incompetence and the way that they
didn't care about
their job or they didn't care about the
environment or the product listen
this is a five star product that you're
giving but you try to give it at a cheap
rate
it's a five-star product so what i had
to do at one point
is just to show them the errors that
they were doing
and at some point they were doing coffee
i
i had no cups i had no cups no cups
to bring coffee but then it's part of my
standard so i didn't bring coffee up
let's go oh sir it's gonna be oh you
want coffee at your room it's gonna be
45 to an hour
45 minutes to an hour and then i have
complaints
and then they come down and i'm like hey
i brought this
up a lot but i don't have any cups
yeah but yeah but they still screw but
they still scream at you yeah they feel
as a matter of fact when there was a new
management that came on she tried to get
rid of me
i told her what the issues were but if
she's the new person in place and i'm
the one bringing up the
all the problems that there there is and
the the higher people that just bought
the
the hotel are telling her well you know
we want this to be cost effective and
this that
um me complaining is bringing more car
costs
because i need there's more cost that
needs to be on there
to fit in order to fix the problem they
don't want to hear that they want to be
cheap i used to work at um
i didn't work i used to volunteer at a
soup kitchen it was on fridays
uh back when i was in high school and
then after i was done my 40 hours i just
kept going i don't know i kind of like
going there and serving food and there's
always homeless people who come uh
pretty much homeless people are people
who
who and you would see people with all
forms of mental health conditions
yup and you know what some of the times
when they were trying to manage it you
could tell like there were some tense
moments
there was some very real discomfort but
these are people who are suffering from
very difficult things that they may have
not diagnosed
or will never get diagnosed because we
as a society have really put these
issues on the back burner
or want to constantly push them off and
as we drive people towards more
isolation
more loneliness more just self
more people are developing these issues
at astronomical rates
and so i think i think i understand the
desire to want to videotape
everything but i also have to ask at
what cost
when a phone literally comes in between
you and another human being
how are you supposed to connect and
conversate with people to understand
them when you're constantly consuming
them
through this medium that's why as great
as youtube stuff is it's never going to
amount to the stuff that i get from the
people in my life
right it matters how you consume folks
and when you're just looking at a camera
to try to get the person perfectly in
frame
you miss the ability to connect and
maybe see some of the dots like yo this
person may be going through some [ __ ]
maybe i instead of trying to constantly
look for culpability in somebody else
maybe what i should be doing is try to
understand the situation better
sometimes i'm dealing with customer
service right and even though i'm
frustrated with the policy in front i'm
like you know what
i know it's not your fault because this
is a policy in the way that it's placed
but you're the person in front of me so
i'm not going to get mad at you
but get me to somebody who can't help me
you do what i'm saying
and if you can't then let's just leave
it at the end i'm going to walk away i'm
going to be
displeased but i'm not going to yell at
you because you're at the front desk
you know why because generally it's the
people who are poorest
who have the least control and the least
power who bear the brunt
of decisions that hey they had little to
no part in
and we make them pay we make them pay
so that's the sad part for me i just
hope that
when you guys come away from this that
we just have a little bit more patience
with each other
a little more understanding okay and
us also be mindful like if you're gonna
post something online and all this other
stuff just just be mindful
of if whether or not the person across
from you is vulnerable
that's the biggest thing we had somebody
who was going through a shitty day
we filmed them having a shitty date and
we laughed at them
yeah that guy that was filming was
trying to make that dude
that punched his his computer
looked like a karen while the biggest
character and
was the one filming yeah that's a
carrying move
yep that's what you're trying to do i
want to speak to your manager
you posting it online you see what your
employee did
it's a white input you try to make it a
race thing on top of that
you're the biggest karen yep you you you
talking about white women doing whatever
you're the biggest white woman out of
the two [ __ ] that was on that
video yep the
guy filming you was a you was a
carringer at that point yep i agree with
you transcended that
i agree with you 110 so yeah that's how
i feel about the whole situation i hope
the person
you know continues to get the help that
they help and they find a different job
i know they started a gofundme for the
individual in question
uh to help them out i don't know how i
feel about gofundme in general but if
you guys want to support
uh you guys can certainly google that um
but yeah those are my thoughts on this
whole matter
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below and by the way if you
guys leave a like comment subscribe all
that good stuff
it always helps us out when keeping the
numbers up because sometimes you will
youtube can be unfavorable so yeah yup
got that right
foreign
[Music]
oh